THINKS THE ENTIRE EVENT WAS
MOTIVATED BY WHITE RAGE.
DID JOSEPH SEEM ENRAGED?
GENERAL MILLEY'S COMMENTS WERE
SHOCKING BUT NOT TO THE MEDIA
WHO SEES WHERE POLITICAL POWER
CURRENTLY RESIDES.
>> MILLEY DELIVERED A SERMON ON
ANTIRACISM AND
PRO-INTELLECTUALISM.
>> IT WAS GREAT TO SEE THE
GENERAL REINFORCE THE POINT THAT
MORE PEOPLE NEED TO LEARN, MORE
PEOPLE NEED TO ACTUALLY EDUCATE
THEMSELVES.
>> IT WAS SO ENCOURAGING.
>> GENERAL MILLEY NEEDS TO BE
APPLAUDED NOT ONLY TODAY BUT
EVERY SINGLE DAY HE GOES TO
WORK.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW,
INDEPENDENT JOURNALIST GLENN
GREENWALD.
I MEAN, NOW I HAVE SEEN IT ALL.
I HAVE SEEN THE FAR LEFT AND
LIBERALS AND PHONY CONSERVATIVES
NOW COME TO THE MILITARY'S
DEFENSE EVEN WHEN THE MILITARY
APPEARS TO BE GETTING VERY, VERY
POLITICAL.
YOUR REACTION TO ALL OF THIS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WHEN AS
JOURNALISTS DO WE CELEBRATE THE
MILITARY AND NOT JUST ANYONE IN
THE MILITARY BUT THE TOP
MILITARY OFFICIAL, THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF
WEIGHING IN ON EXTREMELY
POLARIZING CULTURAL AND
POLITICAL DEBATES AND APPLAUDING
HIM FOR DOING SO?
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE WANT THE
MILITARY NOT TO DO.
SECONDLY, THE QUESTION ABOUT WHY
WITH THE MILITARY SUDDENLY
EMBRACE WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY
LEFTIST CULTURAL DOGMA, NOT
SOMETHING WE ARE ACCUSTOMED TO
SEEING THE MILITARY DO OVER THE
LAST SEVEN OR EIGHT DECADES, TO
PUT THAT MILDLY IS I THINK A
REALLY INTERESTING QUESTION AND
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE MILITARY
POSTURE IS UNDER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THEY VERY MUCH
WANT TO INITIATE A NEW WAR ON
TERROR, ONE THAT IS AIMED
DOMESTICALLY AND THEY ARE
IDENTIFIED ENEMY IS NOT ISIS OR
AL QAEDA OR RUSSIA OR CHINA OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
THEY SAY THE GRAVEST THREAT TO
NATIONAL SECURITY ARE DOMESTIC
EXTREMISTS AND SPECIFICALLY
WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
BY EMBRACING THIS KIND OF
DOCTRINE THAT SAYS THAT WHITE
SUPREMACY IS PERVASIVE
THROUGHOUT SOCIETY, WHAT THE
GENERAL IS REALLY DOING IS
JUSTIFYING THE WAR ON TERROR AS
ALL THESE JOURNALISTS APPLAUD
HIM FOR DOING SO, IT IS REALLY
QUITE AN AMAZING SPECTACLE.
>> Laura: THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA
THEY HAVE ALREADY SAID THEY HAVE
TO DO THAT IN ORDER TO TAMP DOWN
ON DOMESTIC TERROR AND
EXTREMISM.
WHEN THEY USE SUCH A BROAD TERM
THAT IS FRANKLY MEANINGLESS, THE
WORD "EXTREMISM," WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
EXTREME TO WHOM ON WHAT BASIS?
WHAT ARE THEIR METRICS FOR
DETERMINING EXTREMISM?
YOU SEE THESE MSNBC HOSTS, THIS
IS SO GREAT, THE BOBBY SOCKS AS
OF 2021 WITH MILLEY.
CNN IT WILL NOT SURPRISE HE WAS
JUSTIFYING GENERAL MILLEY'S
COMMENTS WITH ANOTHER GENERAL.
WATCH.
>> HE STATES AN ENEMY THAT IS
BASED ON WHITE RAGE THAT HE IS
TRYING TO GET TO KNOW THE ENEMY
AND HE SAID THIS, WHAT CAUSED
THIS WHITE RAGE?
HOW DO YOU DEFINE IT AND HOW DO
YOU ELIMINATE IT FROM WITHIN THE
MILITARY RANKS?
>> Laura: I GUESS WHITE PEOPLE
ARE THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO CAN GET
ENRAGED THESE DAYS.
I CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE I'M HEARING
THESE WORDS COME OUT OF FORMER
MILITARY, CURRENT MILITARY, NOW
THE ENEMY IS US, MEANING THE
PEOPLE.
>> I THINK IT IS A KEY POINT.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
CHEERED FOR THE WAR ON TERROR IN
THE IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF 9/11
CAME TO UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN YOU
TASK IMMENSE POWER IN THE NAME
OF FIGHTING A WAR THAT IS VERY
AMORPHOUS AGAINST TERRORISM IT
CAN LEAD TO A LOT OF ABUSES AND
IT IS VERY HARD TO END IT ONCE
IT BEGINS.
NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT DOING
THE SAME THING BUT THIS TIME
DIRECTED INWARD AT OUR OWN
CITIZENRY.
THEY ARE VERY FEW THINGS MORE
DANGEROUS THEN EMPOWERING THE
GOVERNMENT TO WAGE A DOMESTIC
WAR AGAINST ITS OWN CITIZENRY
WITHOUT EXTREMELY RESTRICTIVE
CONSTRAINTS ON WHO THEY ARE
TARGETING AT ALL THEY ARE SAYING
IS WE ARE GOING AFTER EXTREMISTS
AND NOT JUST EXTREMISTS BUT
WHITE EXTREMISTS IN PARTICULAR.
THE OTHER DISTURBING PART IS THE
GENERAL McCAFFREY, A FOUR-STAR
GENERAL WHO NOW WORKS AT
NBC NEWS CAME ON AND SAID YOUR
COLLEAGUE'S TUCKER CARLSON,
OTHER PEOPLE OF FOX NEWS
INCLUDING YOURSELF WHO
CRITICIZED GENERAL MILLEY OUGHT
TO BE FIRED IMMEDIATELY AS
THOUGH NOW IT IS OFF LIMITS TO
EVEN CRITIQUE MILITARY OFFICIALS
I SUPPOSE IN THE NAME OF
DEMOCRACY BUT THESE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BABBLED ABOUT FASCISM FOR
FIVE YEARS ARE NOW CHEERING
GENERALS, DEMANDING JOURNALISTS
TO BE FIRED FOR THE CRIME OF
CRITICIZING GENERALS WHEN THEY
INTERVENE IN OUR POLITICS.
IT'S A REALLY DISTURBING CLIMATE
THAT IS BEING CREATED.
>> Laura: AFTER 20 PLUS YEARS
WE WERE NOT ABLE TO OVERCOME THE
TALIBAN